les jardins familiaux c'est plus de 2000
mètres carrés appartenant à la chapelle
saint mina objectif favoriser le lien
social
emilia de barrow adore chardy elle
cultive avec un soin jaloux sa parcelle
de son mètre carré j'en prenne deviner
les betteraves vinet c'est comme si on
faisait un
arrosage
de dos ça fait plus deux mois et demi
qui pleut pas alors donc en visant un
petit peu ça nous permet de
garder un petit peu d'eau autour des
betteraves
tout pousse à chez moi des fleurs et
toutes sortes de légumes comme les choux
les les radis les betteraves
j'ai du fenouil j'ai du sélery rares g10
oignons de toutes sortes de légumes vous
avez la main verte il paraît
dans ses jardins familiaux qui compte
douze parcelles la charte interdit
l'utilisation de pesticides les seuls
produits qui sont autorisés sur les
produits bio par exemple pour les angles
en grèce et l'ortie le purin d'ortie
donc j'utilise du purin d'ortie il n'ya
que ça et la binette l'eau est utilisée
avec parcimonie et les jardiniers ne
manquent pas d'astuce comme le paillage
on arrose la paille conserve l'humidité
pendant deux jours ou trois jours ce qui
fait que l'on n'est pas obligé d'arroser
tous les soirs donc on arrose deux fois
par semaine à peu près encore plus
économe emilia de baroin a recours au
système d elle récupère l'eau de pluie
toujours le système d des tubes en pvc
transformer entoura fraises tous les
deux jours deux jours peu près j'en ai
une petite barque elle les excédents des
jardins familiaux sont offerts à la
banque alimentaire
emilia de barrow a trouvé ici sa corne
d'abondance